today i'm going to be speaking with
talia levin who is author of the book
culture warlords my journey into the
dark web of white supremacy
uh talia great to have you on i
appreciate your time
thank you i appreciate you having me on
so
you did something very interesting which
is you um
and and potentially uh harrowing which
is you
jumped into some of the uh dark recesses
of the internet that i will often
mention but recommend my audience not
dive into
um and this includes uh white supremacy
anti-semitism and all sorts of different
areas
talk a little bit about why you did this
and sort of how you dipped your toes
into this pool to begin with
yeah so um i'm a jewish woman
and i've been writing about the far
right for a few years
before the book even came out and um
with that came a response from the white
supremacist white power community
and um my reaction to various waves of
harassment
you know that were vehemently
misogynistic vehemently anti-semitic
was essentially to instead of kind of
curling up and and shrinking back and
stopped talking
was to dive deeper i wanted to see who
these people were where they were coming
from
how they were getting to my twitter feed
and um
you know it was sort of a situation
where the abyss was looking at me
and i decided to gaze back and uh
drag what i saw back out into the light
so what what did you find about the
source of many of the
the sort of hateful and trolling
messages that you were getting
so i decided to take a broad view
and and look at both the development of
the contemporary
white power movement and um
what it looks like how it manifests and
where
they congregate so i spent a lot of time
looking at particularly an encrypted
chat app called
telegram um and
which has like very strong free speech
protections and sort of never
bans content really so it's become kind
of a
thriving ground for white supremacists
who particularly in 2019 faced
some bannings from mainstream social
media like facebook and twitter and so
that's where i spent a lot of my book
research looking into
um and i found a lot of different
tendencies and communities
of interest within the white power
movement that
i spend the book culture warlords
exploring
did you um talk a little bit about how
you existed in some of these spaces i
mean did you develop a character a
series of characters alter egos that
that you kind of um
took on yeah so i didn't actually set
out to write a gonzo journalism book
it's just that when you're a jewish
woman and when you've been kind of an
outspoken
anti-fascist for years
it's hard to get in the front door
people who are white supremacists won't
grant you an interview
you know i one of my earlier
attempts was to try and get into there's
a
sort of power lifting based
uh white supremacist pagan
cult that um that has these solstice
celebrations and i tried to get in just
as a reporter
um and much later one of the guys i was
talking to was like oh we would never
let a jew in
um anyway so you know it was hard to get
in the front door
um but and so as a result i found myself
sort of having to get a little creative
and
find these back door routes and that
included um making sock puppets
you know sock puppet accounts um
to just kind of squat and listen and in
some other cases
having to be a little more proactive and
inventing kind of
identities from whole cloth in order to
get into more private
chats and um uh in one case
i infiltrated a white supremacist dating
site
whitedate.net um you know with a whole
character um who didn't look like me
or have my background um as kind of a
coarse brooklyn jew and i got
these forlorn white supremacists looking
for love to write love letters to their
ideal white wife
and send them to me and i printed them
in the book and it was sort of a
car crash between nicolas sparks and
mineconf
did you make any uh of what you would
consider to be
friends during this process um
no i mean it's not generally my
uh my practice to make friends with
people who want me dead
right but um within my character i mean
i had
i i was i tried not to be like that
active an infiltrator you know what i
mean you don't want to be the one
amping up the stochastic terror you want
to say just enough to pass
and remain in the room um but
in one particular event there was sort
of a
an mma fight being organized between
pagan white supremacists and christian
white supremacists to support
the uh presidential run of a white
nationalist satanist
and so i got deeply involved in the
planning chats for that group and wound
up talking
pretty extensively to one christian
extremist
and telling him all about how his
fascist love of christ had saved my life
just funny things to have to do from my
apartment in brooklyn
as far i'm interested in this religious
component in in your experience
kind of weaving your way through these
communities you know we know about
um the christian roots of the kkk as an
example but at the same time there are
many people who get pulled into white
nationalism
and white supremacy who are not
particularly religious how relevant was
religion
would you say in these different
enclaves
well the group that i was studying
primarily were sort of these radicalized
white power guys right we know that
within the mainline sort of maga
movement which has its fascistic
undertones
um religion plays quite a large role
um this idea that trump is selected by
god and we must fight for him
and everyone else is served satan um
the group that i was speaking to tended
to skew younger
were a little more disaffected with
religion but what they
really took from religion in the case of
the christian white supremacists there
was this
absolute fixation on the crusades um
as kind of a lost cause this battle
between
noble white warriors and swarthy
interlopers that they kind of
interposed onto contemporary
uh anti-immigrant anti-muslim
uh dialogue so it was kind of like them
viewing themselves as crusaders and
flying the templar cross at racist
rallies
um in the case of pagan white
supremacists
heathen white supremacists you have this
fixation on
uh vikings um this idea of white
manliness and the idea of the norse
pantheon as an indigenous
white european religion and one of the
things that sort of
surprised and tickled me uh was that
many heathen white supremacists are
drawn to
the worship of the norse pantheon by the
idea that christianity
was started by a jew and is thus
tainted by the jewish taint forever and
so
you can literally be jesus christ and
that's not enough for some anti-semites
which was sort of a funny discovery to
make
the uh the people you came across what
portion did you get this i mean this
it could be just difficult to tell but
did you get a sense of what portion
would be willing to sort of uh go and
actually take violence into their own
hands in the real world versus how many
of them
are sort of existing in these online
spaces and that's as far as they're
willing to go
so when i tallied up the telegram groups
i was involved in and of course that's
not
the most scientific measure but i joined
between 90 and 100 of these chats and
collectively they had tens of thousands
of members sure right
and one of the big problems facing
researchers and journalists in this area
is that it's quite simply very hard to
tell
which young man spewing violent and
genocidal
rhetoric is going to be the one that
snaps so
you know i have a close friend who is an
anti-fascist and who
was several times threatened directly by
robert bowers who went on to
allegedly shoot um 11
jews in the tree of life synagogue and
it's just very hard to tell it's hard to
tell you know when you're looking at the
sea
of essentially stochastic terror this
sort of perpetual motion machine towards
radicalization
and violence who is going to be the one
to snap and that's why i
talk about how the importance isn't
necessarily the raw numbers
yeah but about the tenor of the
conversation
um and you know when you are marinating
in stochastic terror marinating in
racial violence
marinating in the dehumanization of your
supposed racial enemies
you know this is an environment that's
specifically
cued to get people to snap to radicalize
to engage in violence to stockpile guns
when i um have interviewed former
white nationalists and white
supremacists um
including you know folks like frank mink
and and many others of these folks who
have now become
anti-racist uh advocates they they
almost unilat almost unanimously tell
the same story about how they were
pulled in which is that
they uh sort of found um either
an attention or what they felt as
support
or a community where they had an absence
of it typically
in their family life growing up like
that's the it's almost cliche
but it's the story they they almost all
tell
did you get any sense of at the
individual level
how the folks you came across ended up
in these movements
yeah i mean particularly on the white
supremacist dating site there was often
kind of a
there was a segment you know in the bios
where people described their politics
and how they
came to be on a white supremacist dating
site and a lot of the stories started
with youtube
there were a lot of divorces um in their
backstories
you know um there were a lot of people
in the military um
you know i would say that the most
consistent theme was a sense of
alienation
right and i think as we all know that
that sense of alienation
lack of community desire for purpose it
crosses socioeconomic lines
um it crosses geographical divides
you know it's really a question of sort
of how deep is your feeling of
alienation
and displacement and that can have a lot
of different causes
um i think it's a mistake when people
say oh it's just toothless cletus you
know in his mother's basement you know
when what i saw was really a movement
that spanned
geographical lines socioeconomic lines
these were people with lives and
sometimes spouses
um sometimes people who are in college
you know
the the the myth that everyone is sort
of southern and uneducated
um is really a self-absolving myth that
white liberals use to say it couldn't be
anyone in my neighborhood
couldn't be anyone in my school or my
hoa when in fact it could
it's just a matter of people feeling
lost and
the white supremacist white power
movement really offering you
this mythos of you can become involved
you can save the white race we will give
you a sense of purpose
in your life and i think a lot of us are
looking for a sense of purpose a lot of
us are feeling lost and alienated and
we all find that in different ways um
but that's the sort of compelling
argument they make is
is here's a chance to be part of a
community of people
saving the white race yeah what's
interesting about that
is you know there's a similar pattern to
a lot of the people that get sucked into
the cult of trumpism which is
believing that it will provide solutions
to problems that may well be real um but
but they get tricked about where the
solutions are and that seems to be a
kind of interesting overlap in hearing
hearing you describe it yeah i mean i
think
that's true of any sort of radicalizing
movement right
yeah is that they look at you um look at
your vulnerabilities look at what you're
seeking and then
become that you know love bomb you
um although frankly the tenor of
conversation is quite purile and
uh often very cruel there's not a lot of
love bombing going on but there is a
sense of like
you are a warrior you know um
there's really a regression into very
toxic
and narrow gender roles this this idea
of kind of
you will be a manly man a warrior um
for the white race um an encouragement
towards survivalism towards stacking up
guns
um but really this sense of kind of
propping up embattled masculinity
and making that be part
of a community
that has this sort of overall
quote-unquote noble purpose
the book is fascinating it's culture
warlords my journey
into the dark web of white supremacy
we've been speaking with the book's
author talia levin talia i so appreciate
your time today
thank you so much yeah and um the book
is available on
amazon at your local indie store which
you should please support during the
pandemic
and uh everywhere books are sold and it
goes into great
detail about not just contemporary white
supremacy but its roots